this is the jocko underground podcast
number five with echo charles and me
jocko willink good evening echo good
evening and also joining us tonight is
good deal dave burke good evening dave
good evening all right so we've been
getting crazy
uh talking about
competing but
tonight i at the opening of the podcast
tonight i kind of went a little bit
deep on
thinking strategic versus thinking
tactical
so
i was thinking about that
and i started thinking about look it's
so obvious isn't it so obvious that we
should be thinking strategic all the
time isn't it so obvious it seems so
obvious right
why isn't it happening so i started
thinking about okay what are the enemies
what are the enemies
of strategic thinking
what are they what can they be they've
got to be out there
because otherwise we would just be
thinking strategic all the time
but if everyone was thinking strategic
all the time the world would be an
entirely different place
and certainly every individual's world
would be an entirely different place
so what's causing it
first thing that comes to my mind ego
why is that
what is the ego how does ego drive us to
not think strategically well because our
ego is that thing that is
not comfortable with
giving a tactical victory to someone
else
i mean so i would rather
win an argument with dave burke
hurt our relationship make him look bad
devolve
our business relationship our personal
i'd rather do all that because i want to
win an argument
with dave
why because that's my ego talking
that is such a driver
of doing dumb things
you know what's really crazy is when
people do
when people do dumb things based on
their ego and it actually
it actually
you can destroy like your whole company
right you can have a whole company that
gets destroyed by ego
you can do i mean you certainly can have
people there's examples of battles that
have taken place where ego caused defeat
and cost
you know hundreds or thousands of people
their lives
based just on
ego
just on hey we can take these guys hey
my plan is gonna like that happens
that's a real thing
so
when we talk about that i also wanna
talk about okay so how do you how do you
defeat this enemy of how do you defeat
this enemy
of strategic thinking if it's your ego
how do you how do you do that well
to me
you've got to
and this is the answer i'm going to say
this answer over and over again
you got to detach
and you got to think about what you're
doing
which
what a novel idea
to actually detach and think about what
you're doing
and oddly enough this gives you this
massive strategic advantage if you can
take a four inch step backwards
detach from your ego and look at what's
actually playing out
if you can do that you're you're like
infinitely better
than you are if your ego's all wrapped
up in this decision that you're making
it's crazy that it would come to that
you ever seen the breakfast club
remember that movie yes it's old school
right you see now right that's your jump
the
okay remember the part when he was like
hey uh i made i like we want like
early quarantine yeah you know when it
was like well what are we doing you know
and the kids were home my daughters were
home for college from college and all
that and we're sitting around so we i i
said okay we're gonna watch some 80s
movies
i went old school
breakfast club was on the list it was
one of the few
that kind of passed muster because some
of the other movie i'll tell you
because i have a daughter that she was
10 when quarantine kicked off and all
that
have you have you watched e.t
like recently
like 10 years ago maybe
wait what do you mean it passed muster
like like like the family was like oh
that was pretty good yeah it was okay
because now they were
there was a time where there's like
we're not watching any more of your
stupid movies as a matter of fact my
youngest daughter when i say when i say
to my young startup oh do you want to
watch a movie she's like from what year
and e.t is one of the ones that sort of
put the nail in the coffin on 80s movies
have you dave have you ever seen you
seen e.t
well totally seen et have you seen it in
the last three years five years yes
did it pass muster
um
it hasn't had
it hasn't been watched since and it's
one of those that like the itunes
scenario i'm like i'm just gonna buy it
because once they see it they're gonna
watch it a bunch
nobody has gone back to one shot and i
was i hadn't seen it in probably 20
something years but i was so sure that i
wasn't gonna waste my time with the
rental i'm buying it because it's gonna
be on repeat
nobody's gone back to that well that you
and i walked into that ambush
the exact same way it's crazy i 100
because i don't i don't i don't you said
you haven't seen it in 20 years i saw it
in the theater yeah so whatever year it
came out 1983
so i was like 12 years old i went to the
theater and watched it
and i remember it being this moving
story
and i was expecting and my uh
my wife you know she's a
let's say she will she's no she will get
emotional during a movie right you know
she'll get sad and my youngest daughter
is kind of the same way you know you'll
see the tears welling up
so i'm thinking oh you know we're taking
down this little emotional thing i'm
kind of thinking well you know i better
check myself too because you know when
et's going home you know i don't want to
be the i don't want to be the guy that's
breaking down
during e.t no
bro it was hard my my youngest daughter
it was hard for her to even kind of
watch the whole thing
and part of it is the freaking special
effects nowadays i mean when you see e.t
looking like a looking like a looking
like a someone's like holding it behind
and shaking it to make it look like it's
walking
super lame
super lame but but and that was bad but
then actually what was weird to me is
like the story wasn't as good as i
remember
and that movie was a blockbuster
it was a blockbuster
interesting why was it a blockbuster
special effects allegedly i don't know
because i mean damn yeah standard below
yeah i don't know i don't know i got no
answer this time
but yeah that the e.t the the kids
nowadays they're well my daughter she's
seven
um where she'll like you know they can
they're at that age and older they can
identify
current special effects in old school
special effects well you make those
little movies with your kids in them
yeah why are we watching why are we
watching a puppet yeah exactly right
move all super whack
yeah yeah so et
didn't really pass the muster
um
dang uh ferris bueller's day off
didn't really pass muster and even i was
sort of like wow i thought i remem i
remember these things as they were
pretty good
right uh and and and breakfast club
breakfast and there was a i'm trying to
think of some other ones
that that we watched but but breakfast
club
past muster interesting past mustard
dang it not
yeah i know that's weird for us seemed
like that was the adventure yeah it did
seem that way so you were referring to
breakfast club yeah do you even have any
idea why you're referring to breakfast
club yes i do it's a very critical point
that you you brought up actually about
how your ego you can watch as someone's
ego just drives their whole
interests into the ground and defeats
them all of them completely to zero
so breakfast club there was a time where
he came and he and uh
what's that what's the principle or
whatever the guy's name is
something like this
but i i don't know i can't remember he
came in and he was like
you know said his thing and he's like
i don't know i think he screwed you do
you have any more questions and he said
yeah i have a question he's like does
barry madame manilow know that you
raided his wardrobe yeah i said i'll
give you the answer to that question
next saturday yeah right like you got
another saturday detention
and um then he kept going with it right
like kind of like whatever i forget
exactly his response to that one was and
he's like
he's like oh
oh no he's like i i'm not free or
something like that he's like oh i'm
free anyway he goes he's like you want
to keep going yeah and he's like and he
ends up with the horns yeah the fingers
two months
two months bender i got you for two
months to the point where and like just
like how you said you can watch people
as they just do it and meanwhile so the
girl
i mean i was referring to i was
referring to battles where thousands of
people have been killed because of
something but bender didn't get two
months worth of detention same exact
deal same exact deal
so molly ringwald
ringwald yeah yeah she's like she's
straight up sitting there saying hey
stop she's like cut it out dude i can't
watch this anymore yeah and bro that's
how right everyone's like can see it and
brother guy wasn't detached at all his
ego was just flaring up front lines all
day two months of detention yeah two
months i got you for two months you mess
with the bull
you get the horns
all right so
we gotta watch out for you go our ego is
a enemy of strategic thinking you could
end up with two months of saturday
detentions or what have you or
you could end up leading people to death
in combat
both of these apparently are
big huge strategic
defeats
another thing
uh
that is an enemy of strategic thinking
this one's real obvious instant
gratification right whatever that
instant gratification is
it
it oddly enough can just crush
a long-term strategic victory because
you want immediate gratification right
now
doughnut
that one's such a weird one right there
the immediate gratification like you
know it it's like you see it right there
in front you see the whole thing
it's not like something's gonna sneak
out of the and and surprise you you know
you know straight up
yeah and you just do it like like saving
money right you know that one you save
money then you see that thing that you
don't even need yeah i in desperate was
freedom field manual i was
then the new addition i wrote a little
section about getting ambushed by we
like as if the donut ambushes you as if
that's what happens
as if the alarm clock snooze button
somehow
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen
go to
jockounderground.com and subscribe and
we're doing this to mitigate our
reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better communications with us
strengthen this legion of troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and eighteen cents a month
and if you can't afford to support us we
can still support you just email
assistance at jocko underground.com and
we'll get you taken care of until then
we will see you
mobilized
underground